begin with breaking news at 4 30 summer  camp canceled at a local school after a  threatening phone call madison kimbrough  joining us now live with all the details  madison  it's still unclear what was said in that  threatening phone call received here at  the meadow school but we can confirm  that the school's administration staff  made the decision to cancel camp all  this week because of it the camp known  as camp mustang is a summer camp  designed for children ages 3 to 14 and  offers a mix of academic arts and sports  theme activities from what we've seen on  their website camp mustang started in  the beginning of june and was supposed  to run until july 29th but as of now all  campers have been sent home so keep it  here on 8 news now as this is a  developing story we learn more details  you can learn more information on air  and online reporting live madison  kimbrough live local now